hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
five nights at freddy's help wanted hi
am i supposed to wave at you i'm waving
oh that looked like a middle finger but
don't mind that
hey you're just like me you got weird
green hands that's probably connected
also this doesn't say out of order
anymore
oh what did i do oh [ __ ]
whoa oh i hate it oh okay actually i
hate that that's awful
what did i just do what oh
oh wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa what the [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh oh
oh okay i don't like being a void of
death
uh this looks like a void of death i
don't know what this is but
you hello oh can you hear me
yes don't exit this room okay this isn't
a mistake
this room isn't a mistake i had to hide
these logs away from the core gameplay
files
in a place that only a beta tester would
look and in a place where the files
could be protected
uh i just really really hope that the
next development team finds this before
the game is released to the public
okay this game has some kind of
malicious code in it
that we haven't been able to fully
contain uh-huh don't even understand for
that matter
we're over budget and out of time but
that's not the reason that we're
shutting down
listen i have to keep this short so the
file size will be small enough to fly
under the radar there are more they may
not be in order
oh oh
oh okay i hate this place um okay
i saw it for the first time today what
there was a character i couldn't make
out who it was
standing at the end of the hall i
thought it was just
bugged out so i made a note of it and
kept playing
but then it was looking in the window
and not like chica or bonnie would
it was like it was actually looking in
the window seeing what i was doing
huh oh
okay i don't like how quiet i heard a
pretty heated conversation this morning
between dale our manager
and someone else on the line it really
feels like this project is in trouble
in no small part because of the lawsuit
i'm sure
there has to be a lawsuit there's no way
there isn't what the [ __ ]
it happened in this building just a few
doors down for me
i think it's made worse by the fact that
jeremy tried to tell us something was
wrong
but as a dev team we all just saw it as
a challenge to find what the problem was
and fix it oh who could have known that
i have to go okay you have to go perfect
have you ever heard of a guillotine
paper slicer yes it sounds made up
but it's an actual piece of office
equipment i didn't even know we had one
in the supply room
i guess the more common at businesses
that do a lot of graphic design work
i remember seeing one when i was still
in school and even then
i knew how dangerous it looked i was
always afraid of losing a finger
that seems so silly now jeremy used to
do design work
i guess that's how he knew it was there
wha
that's nonsensical nothingness that
means nothing
what are you talking about what does
that even mean oh [ __ ] we're still here
oh god oh wait wait wait a minute
wait night five wait night five
oh wow wow
wow whoa whoa whoa so there's a there's
a freaking hard mode
oh god hang on i want to see showtime
baby what is this button on this
ow that was my mic sorry
button on side i don't know what that do
there's my mic
i don't know where i am uh let's go out
of
[ __ ] mode
[Music]
hey oh you're not there anymore actually
wait let's go back in
i wanna see something you're not there
okay you're not there but i'm gonna go
to the prize counter while i'm in weird
mode
anything weird okay
candy oh whoa
whoa you were hidden okay
i found you though okay that's another
tape i i guess
the drawers have been emptied out
someone was here
i don't think it was spring cleaning
either no no
there was plastic on the floor someone
was definitely here during the night
it had to have been the client i mean
they sent us that stuff in the first
place with no explanation
told us to scan it said it would
expedite the process so we wouldn't need
to program any path finding ourselves
oh it was a budget thing i guess oh yeah
budget it was just
junk circuit boards and things like that
yeah okay
look pretty old somehow though there was
usable coat on something yeah it seemed
to take hold by itself oh that's normal
things started changing
but then he started appearing
at least that's what jeremy said right
okay yeah that makes total sense
total sense yeah usable code that you
just grab from a circuit board and put
in your game
how you doing there oh you're fine no i
like you
i like you i like you okay all right i'm
gonna get out of here
uh uh cachunkus uh bye-bye oh you're
still there okay
are you closer wait a minute are you
closer
are you waving more vigorously hi i
cannot wave you
[ __ ] okay so um that's that's a no-no
uh so we got these other uh other
things to do but i i've also never
finished
five nights at freddy's one for this
so i'm gonna go ahead and um
i'm gonna do that if you don't mind
because
i don't mind but if you don't mind i'm
gonna go ahead and finish up
five nights at freddy's one because i'm
i don't want that to be you know not
here so whoo oh [ __ ]
oh god no none of that okay so um
holy [ __ ] i just got the yeah
okay we're fine i remember how to play
the game i do
wait what didn't they say something
about their son being something out this
hall
i have no idea hey this is the door
the other one [ __ ] you man
oh celebrate yeah okay celebrate yes
celebrate my ass
okay all right we already got bonnie on
the move here so that's okay
it's fine until they get to the door
did i press that okay whatever i didn't
mean to press that okay you move
oh oh we got two on the move hey
wait oh that's awful i hate that
all right that's awful um everything
else is fine
ugh i don't like that okay oh god okay
all right we're fine
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay turn okay you're i'm
i'm
fine i panicked for nothing okay
i hate that okay hate that i see neither
of them okay bonnie's coming down that
way
i hear something over here i swear to
god i hear something
okay i hear something i don't know what
i'm hearing but i'm hearing something
no good oh my god okay bonnie's still
there
where's chica where's stephen
oh my god what why who and why what was
there there was nothing there
what was there nothing you liar don't
lie to me
don't lie to me what was hey oh okay
you're in the closet that's fine oh
foxy okay i don't know what what
no no no way wait a minute oh
[ __ ] what
uh-huh okay i'm getting better at
hitting the door lights
so that's good foxy is not there okay
we're fine we're fine okay i don't like
that what is that
look at the music get the music you [ __ ]
okay you're there
that's fine you're not there yet i don't
think
okay no no no whoa what the [ __ ] wait
but i wait oh god why
oh [ __ ] okay you're there but that's
fine okay you're you're not
there you're behind my door for some
reason i don't know why
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay but that's fine
you're you're on the move i think
you're still fine oh [ __ ]
oh god okay you're fine you're moving
you move out here
oh god why [ __ ] hey
oh god you moving down oh you're fine
you're fine you're fine it's fine
technically speaking i hate that oh i
hate that oh my god i hate that
okay i hate that um well we're fine what
[ __ ] okay you're fine are you still
there okay you're gone okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my dick okay oh [ __ ]
okay well here we go
okay cool you're still there
[Music]
okay i tried it
i tried to okay you're not there anymore
ah you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
i don't know man okay where's foxy up
who knows
freddy's still on the stage uh you still
there
ah why are you still there [ __ ]
why are you still there i can't see when
you go back
i guess i gotta wait for you to pop up
on stage again for some reason
turn off okay oh my god okay
are you back on stage no you're still
there probably
i don't know you haven't gone anywhere
go away
oh my god are you still there are you
gone
have you gone home oh my god finally
okay
stop look here no stop okay okay where
are they i don't know there's bonnie
okay there's bonnie there
okay little touches little tooches
little tooches
just that's all it takes little touches
little tooches that's all it is
4am i've got this in the bag so long as
i keep
touching just little by little oh [ __ ]
okay wait what the [ __ ] oh hi okay
you're fine
you're fine you're fine it's fine this
is really weird that's horrible
but technically it's fine because
the aku has you'll be there and
[ __ ] why why oh [ __ ] no no no wait no
that's a no oh but who the [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god i'm i'm uh this is
bad but i got 30
power so technically i can stay here for
a long time technically
technically speaking i am fine
technically speaking i could stay here
until 6am because i am fine i got plenty
of power left
you all are [ __ ] why don't you go
away oh you're gone are you
okay that's a little power left for me
to save
because i'm a conservatory kind of guy
conservationally is that who's that is
that freddy
is that freddie on the move this is only
night two can i mention that this is
only night two that everyone is being
this
dicky with me okay you're fine stop
oh my god oh [ __ ] okay that [ __ ]
what was that what was that no don't
laugh at me
you're fine [ __ ] ah
okay you're boy you're there and you're
there that's that's good that's that's
actually okay
oh my god two percent holy [ __ ] two
percent
ah ah
[Applause]
oh there i go there goes my power but
it's okay
cause i win
oh oh
oh you you're the worst
oh look at my slappy arms
listen buddy listen what the [ __ ] did i
eat that
what the [ __ ] did i eat that
[Music]
what the [ __ ] did i eat that
did i wait wait a minute did i just eat
that
what do you want to run that
you want to run that by me i ate
what okay
all right sure yeah okay fine
yeah uh uh yeah okay
all right that's that's fine
didn't know that would happen but okay
shut up i don't have time
i know i don't have time
this is good it's good it's a good thing
it's a good stop go away it's a good
thing oh [ __ ]
okay here comes okay here comes chica
but that's okay she could just go
marching on
the chicas go marching on oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa none of that
whoa what the [ __ ] you kidding me
what is happening what is happening
what's happening who's having a circus
you're not there okay you're fine okay
don't don't do that
okay don't do that whatever you just did
don't
do it whatever you're doing right now
don't okay okay
oh boy oh boy i don't see chica nowhere
i don't see chica nowhere i don't see
anybody nowhere oh
[ __ ] okay it's fine it's fine it's fine
oh [ __ ] okay it's
it's not fine okay it's not fine it's
it's big okay you're there that's fine
you stay there oh god
oh [ __ ] okay you're still there that's
fine okay
okay all right that's fine oh and then
we're good
you're still there now you're gone okay
stop that go here look there
i don't know where freddie is but he's a
common
okay but i'm ready i'm ready for freddy
i'm losing a lot of power though so this
is not ideal
i got to be better at jabbing my fingies
okay you're there
you're there oh boy i'm backing
back in old fashion okay i think i saw
freddy on the move there
he was going somewhere oh [ __ ] okay he's
going somewhere
i don't know where i don't know where
and i don't care because i got this
all to myself who's moving who's on the
move
huh okay you again are you gonna stop
and look like a weirdo
no no you're going right back yeah yeah
you should as you should
as you should as you should go by yeah
okay
yeah okay as you should oh [ __ ] okay
okay you're fine it's fine okay that's
fine god this
the original i swear to god the original
so
[ __ ] scary every part of it like
there you are i see you
freddie tucked in the corner there like
the creep you is
okay stop okay go there
looking here i'm checking for bonnie
you're still there that's fine i only
need to look at you
okay you're good you're good okay you're
not there
you're not there okay definitely not
there okay good
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what was that
what was that wait no it's fine
is it fine i don't think it's fine it
doesn't sound fine i don't remember what
that's all about
i think it's fine i think it's fine it's
fine
oh my god okay it's fine it's just noise
it's just a bunch of noise
okay oh [ __ ] was that mine
okay there's okay get
okay you move on right by no no no no no
no
okay [ __ ] okay but you
shouldn't be there okay he's not there
okay you're still there
you're not there oh my god oh my god
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't have enough
power for this what is that
what is that oh my god okay oh you're
gone
are you there okay you're not there but
you might be there god damn it
okay i'm looking [ __ ] okay
what am i looking for i don't know oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay who did that ah okay you're right
there i gotta keep that close cuz i
remember
i remember that's bad news no matter
what that's bad news okay
okay maybe it's not maybe uh maybe i'm
wasting power i probably am can i
get that off there okay okay i think
it's fine i think i'm
panicking with that door oh [ __ ] no well
that's bad anyway
okay it's fine okay
it's fine that's bad news but i'm gonna
die anyway because i'm about to run out
of power
and there's nothing i could do about it
so you know c'est la vie
it was a good run here i go oh [ __ ]
oh please wow
yes yes oh my god
oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] okay let's try not to eat my prize
this time
oh that's worse that's
what i mean it kind of looks tasty i
like your back boobs
um
[Music]
look okay all right so i ate that
i'm not sure why it was tasty though it
was pretty good
super good i liked it but i don't know
why i ate it
didn't know i could eat it you're doing
a great job and no doubt having a great
time as well
as a reminder please be sure to only
interact with core gameplay elements
and avoid anything that could
potentially be considered a glitch
mistake
or embedded message from unauthorized
personnel
okay yeah could you make it any more
obvious for me what i'm supposed to do
mr heavy-handed over there all right one
more night
okay well that's no good but hey that's
not gonna happen to me not this time
because i
am an expert at touching buttons
tuchen tucci's which is what i'm doing
just touching all over the buttons
they're going up here strumming up and
down the two cheese
we're going down to tootstown baby and
i'm gonna touch all over these buttons
so gingerly so gently
no one's going to get me no one's going
to get me no it's going to get me oh my
god everyone's going to get me
oh god okay all right everyone's going
to go why i'm looking right at you
why would you be like that is that just
like something that's going to happen
oh god why okay no reason why but that's
fine
all good everyone everyone's off the
stage so
[ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay that
that's too close okay you're done
the [ __ ]
you weren't done were you you weren't
done i guess you weren't done all right
well
i guess he wasn't done i guess i guess
he wasn't done is the lesson i learned
there all right okay
okay but i was still here steps no no no
but you stay right there you don't mess
with me because i won't mess with you
you don't want these messing fingers
messing with you chica cause i'm about
to mess you up
yes yeah you heard the threat you ran
like a little baby
you ran like a little baby in the face
of pure death
these fingers spelled death and i'm
gonna shove them
so far inside your suit i'm gonna wind
up your spring locks
this is all it is this is all this is
what i remember even in the main game
this is all it was you'd ignore all the
[ __ ] noise that are happening around
you because there's a lot of [ __ ]
noise happening
don't get me wrong there's a lot of that
happening but for me
all i care about okay here comes freddie
he's coming down he i see the eyes
i see the eyes there okay the eyes are
there so freddie's there
okay stop freddy's there
still looking down bonnie hasn't shown
up yet which is fine
how's foxy doing close but that's okay
what are we doing nothing doing nothing
stop god damn it
okay we're doing nothing oh my god oh my
god
oh [ __ ] god i was looking right at
the screen you weren't gone yet
what the [ __ ] that's unfair
i wasn't even gone you weren't even gone
um okay potion oh [ __ ]
that's how i got killed he switched
right as i went to that one
and that's no good that is a no point
okay you're oh [ __ ]
okay you're you're fine
[Music]
oh [ __ ] okay you as soon as this moves
unless you
okay you're fine okay and then you
oh god i'm just gonna close that because
i don't [ __ ] trust that at all
they're both stacked up there that's
how is any of that fair you there no
you're not there
why are you not there oh you're already
about to reset again
okay oh [ __ ] wait what what the [ __ ]
okay apparently not okay oh god what are
you doing
do something god [ __ ] this door okay i'm
gonna open it up again
because i can't waste that power unless
you oh [ __ ] okay
stop in that stop on that you go ahead
try
try me [ __ ] try me yeah try me
try me i'm almost out of power okay
you're there that's fine
okay that's totally fine you're there
you stay there
for as long as you need it's all fine i
got 17 power
i got everything i need right here
we're good there what is that
oh [ __ ] okay he's coming down okay what
are you gonna stop there
oh yeah you are okay [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that noise
can you are now probably right behind
there
so i'm not going to mess with that [ __ ]
unless you are right behind there are
you right behind there oh [ __ ] he's
right behind there isn't he
no what the [ __ ] no
you dick okay who's who's walking up
okay we got we got chica walking up
which is fine
that's a stopwatch i don't like that i
don't like that at all
okay so cheek is moving back
there unless she gets oh [ __ ] okay
you're coming up
which is fine okay you're going by
okay and he's gone so that door is just
staying close from now until eternity
that door is now the closed door
forever i don't need the light i don't
need to know about it
that door just stays closed i don't care
what anybody says
that door's staying closed and then you
did you move no not yet okay
just playing with one door closed that's
it okay and
oh you what oh [ __ ] i don't like that
i don't like that what are you there
[Music]
okay apparently not what the [ __ ] okay i
don't like that i don't trust
that at all hey
[ __ ] okay yes with these hands
i did it oh [ __ ] okay cool
good good great great great great great
great great great great give me my prize
give me my prize oh bonnie
wow you look so good you couldn't
ever eat me you couldn't even dream of
eating me
you couldn't handle the taste that i
have
in my garb and look at that i was right
you can't eat me well oh yeah bonnie
well you can eat my fist no oh boy
[Music]
dead that is the original five nights at
freddy's
[ __ ] terrifying
but hey i did it
so you can take that one home
to the books so thank you everybody so
much for watching
this episode of high night
at ferratti's vr help wanted it's been
fun
they've been real fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching and
there's gonna be more five nights at
freddy's coming
real soon i'll let you guys know when
i'm able to post more but you can just
check my channel
subscribe ring that bell flingling that
like button whatever you want to do
to make sure that you get notified of
new five types of phrase
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check the description for even
more
videos on this wonderful topic and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye